momentan also ganz konkret heute nacht
um 23 uhr 30
sollte es im rahmen einer ganz normalen
polizeikontrolle im rahmen eines
bieterverfahrens zur kontrolle einer
person kommen
diese protonen und gleich ihre frage
vorwegzunehmen ist ein 17 jähriger
deutscher staatsbürger mit weißer
hautfarbe der im bereich beschluss
gartenanlagen eckensee offensichtlich in
rauschgift delikt begangen hat
kontrolliert werden
bei diesem ganz normalen für uns
üblichen einschreiten haben sich sofort
zwei bis dreihundert anwesende personen
dort sage ich mal aus der partyszene und
freitags abends samstagabend szene
solidarisieren haben sofort die
polizeibeamten vor ort massiv
angegriffen mit steinen und flaschen
dürfen die kollegen konnten dann unter
massive verstärkung es erreichen das
sagen wir mal die personen ein stück
weit zurückgedrängt wurden die gruppe
wuchs ständig an und hat sich dann auf
dem schlossplatz das ist unweit der
stelle dass das der kontrollstelle auf 4
bis 500 personen erhöht und von dort an
wurden die polizeibeamten die die
eingeschritten sind massiv mit steinen
und flaschen beworfen polizei haben die
aber an der stelle nicht nur die sondern
auch der rettungsdienst es kam zu einem
medizinischen notfall unter
rettungsdienst wurde an der behandlung
des patienten ebenfalls durch
flaschenwürfe und direkte angriffe
gehindert die gruppe setzt sich zusammen
aus scheinlich aus dem osten und
gruppierungen die wir als event szene
bezeichnen die sich hier dann samstags
in der stadt coesfeld wir haben es nicht
geschafft trotz eines erheblichen kräfte
an aufgebots die situation in der ersten
phase gleich in den griff zu bekommen
sie war außer unüberschaubar für unsere
beamten vor ort
deswegen hat sich aus den direkten
eingriffen haben sich kleine gruppen
gebildet die dann wiederum die
einsatzkräfte an
gegriffen haben und die dann im späteren
verlauf durch die innenstadt gezogen
sind und haben dort diverse straftaten
begangen auf die bilanz komme ich gleich
es gelang uns dann durch massive
unterstützung anderer kräfte und durch
das polizeiliche einschreiten gegen 4
uhr 30 die lage sogar zu beruhigen dass
wir als sagen wir mal einen einigermaßen
überschaubaren zustand in der stadt
hatten
zur bilanz des abends es wurden
insgesamt 24 personen vorläufig
festgenommen
davon waren zwölf personen mit deutscher
staatsangehörigkeit zur person mit
anderer staatsangehörigkeit als deutsch
wir haben insgesamt 19 verletzte
polizeibeamte wobei ein beamter
dienstunfähig ist es vielleicht musste
seinen dienst könnte seinen dienst nicht
fortsetzen
diese zahl könnte sich noch erhöhen
dadurch dass polizeibeamte oftmals im
einsatz dann ihre verletzungen nicht
melden und es dann im nachgang dann
kommt deswegen bitte ich auch diese zahl
unter dem zu eingangs gesagten
einschränkungen zu subsumieren
wir wurden insgesamt im weiteren verlauf
des abends 40 ladengeschäfte angegangen
sage ich jetzt mal ein bisschen
juristischen technik und technische es
wurden schaufensterscheiben beschädigt
oder zerstört nach jetzigem sachstand
gehen wir davon aus dass neuen laden
geschäfte geplündert wurden in
verschiedenen ausprägungen stufen das
ist momentan alles noch grundlage der
ermittlungen werde natürlich muss man
jetzt erstmal schauen wie hoch sind die
sachschäden was wurde entwendet das wird
noch einige tage dauern bis man weiß was
da passiert ist von den 24 personen
werden heute mindestens sieben dem
haftrichter vorgeführt
um sie eine prüfung einer
untersuchungshaft zuzuführen
insgesamt wurden mehrere
polizeieinsatz fahrzeuge beschädigt
stand heute 12 und teilweise mit
totalschaden so beschädigt dass sie
nicht mehr einsatzfähig waren
die polizei hatte heute nacht insgesamt
280 polizistinnen und polizisten im
einsatz wovon 200 polizeibeamtinnen und
polizeibeamten von uns vom
polizeipräsidium stuttgart waren und
circa 100 von anderen unterstützt wurden
nach den sachverhalten haben wir sofort
die kriminalpolizei alarmiert die in der
ersten phase mit über 40 beamten eine
ermittlungsgruppe eingerichtet haben
die sich jetzt um diese themen kümmert
diese ermittlungsgruppe heißt
ermittlungsgruppe eckensee